some of America's neighbors and closest
allies are fighting back after the Trump
administration hit Europe Mexico and
Canada with new import tariffs starting
today the US will place a 25 percent
tariff on imported steel a 10 percent
tariff on aluminum leaders from the EU
Mexico and Canada
say they'll retaliate with some tariffs
on American exports the moves raise
fears of a larger trade war head O'Keefe
is in Falls Church Virginia with the
potential impact on US businesses and
consumers head good morning good morning
John president Trump's decision could
mean big tariffs on various American
goods after Mexico Canada and European
Union put tariffs on them could mean
higher prices for things like instant
coffee and this harley-davidson
motorcycle why would they go after a hog
because it's made in Wisconsin the home
state of House Speaker Paul Ryan these
tariffs are totally unacceptable at a
press conference Thursday Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau condemned
president Trump's tariff decision the
White House says the tariffs are a
national security issue and that a
reliance on imported metals is a
security risk
French president Emmanuel macron called
the decision illegal while the President
of the European Commission called the
move protectionism pure and simple they
were joined by several top Republicans
including House Speaker Paul Ryan who
said there are better ways to help
American workers and consumers we're
gonna make a fair NAFTA deal much better
than the decision comes amid stalled
NAFTA negotiations during which the
president told his neighbors they would
receive a permanent tariff exemption if
they agreed to US demands critics warned
that by antagonizing close allies the
administration could be causing prices
to rise for Americans on everyday items
the Mexican government is punching back
by putting tariffs on US products like
flat steel Canada is threatening tariffs
on twelve point eight billion dollars
worth of American goods like coffee
pizza even quiche many parts of the
country depend on those exports and many
are in states the president carried in
2016 but Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross
says fears of a trade war
are overblown these are blips in the
radar screen
everybody has bats every now and again
the new tariffs come as the Trump
administration tries to avoid a trade
war with the world's second largest
economy China both countries are
threatening up to 200 billion dollars of
tariffs on each other's goods Commerce
Secretary Ross is headed to Beijing
today in hopes of smoothing things over
Gayle okay not the key shed not the keys
thank you very much